(laughs)
- I feel like I just made
out with a gingerbread man.
It's delicious.
(grandiose orchestral music)
- I personally love Harry Potter.
- I remember seeing the
cover and I was like,
"I have to read this."
- My relationship to Harry
Potter, I've never met the man.
- I'm so excited.
(laughs)
(mysterious orchestral music)
- This drink is beautiful.
- Holla!
- This is a tall glass of sexy right here.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Oh, that's sweet.
- Yeah.
- My goodness, that's so sweet.
- That's the stuff.
- Oh, that's good.
- It's caramelly--
- Oh (beep).
I mean--
- It's butterscotchy.
- Just happiness in a cup.
- It could use a little
more salt, I think.
- Part of me wants to
say it can't be related
to anything else, it's
exclusive to Harry Potter
and butterbeer, but the other half of me
wants to say cream soda.
- I could knock back a
few of these with Dobby.
- Oh, easy. (laughs)
- And the other house
elves in the basement.
- I could drink this every day.
I could have this for breakfast,
start off my day this way.
(laughs)
(uplifting orchestral music)
- So this is the frozen one.
- Oh!
- This one looks like a milkshake.
- Well, cheers.
- If Hogsmeade had a 7-11,
this would be their slurp,
or slushie or slurpie.
- Oh my gosh.
- It's not as sweet.
It tastes kind of a little
bit watery, dare I say?
- It's sad that I wanna say this tastes
like a caramel frappuccino.
- Oh, better!
- But better.
- The other one is also really good
and it has a lot more of the creamy top.
I keep on saying "creamy
top" and I'm like.
(laughs)
- So here's the thing, so
Harry Potter almost always
went back to the Muggle
world in the summers
and that's when he would
want to drink this.
- I wouldn't wanna know how
much sugar is in this, though.
- It doesn't count in Harry Potter World.
- Got the ice cream headache.
- Oh yeah, my throat is like (gags).
- What's the spell to get rid of that?
- You can't do spells at the table.
- Oh.
(lively orchestral music)
- It's nice and warm, cheers.
- This is how I imagined butterbeer, TBH.
- I hope this is a
transformative of an experience
as pumpkin spice latte was.
(laughs)
- Oh, it smells like a candle.
- I feel like this is gonna
be a very hipster butterbeer.
- What?
- Oh
- Holy (beep).
- Whoa. (coughs)
- I wanna enjoy this in private.
It's just one of those, it's so good.
- I feel like they melted down a waffle.
- It tastes like buttered
corn on the cob, kind of.
- Yeah, I disagree. (laughs)
It's way better than
corn on the cob. (laughs)
- This is like Christmas in a cup.
- This is my perfect everything.
- I don't know, I
honestly, I know I'm taking
the easy road out right
here, but I cannot pick one.
- The hot one, the frozen one.
- Can you triple--
- All day every day.
- The hot one is definitely my favorite.
This defied all my expectations.
- This one's my favorite one
'cause it's the more subtle
of the tastes.
- The butterbeer at the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter
is everything that I dreamed it would be.
Specifically the hot butterbeer.
- Yes.
- Holy crap.
- This was my favorite one.
I just wanna bathe in this.
- I would do alohomora (laughs)
and have it just floating
behind me and then hold the other two.
(lively orchestral music)
- I think it was actually
alcoholic in the books.
They were getting tipsy.